ممكن تكون ضمن اعلى واحد في المئه من
اصحاب الدخل في بلادك لكن على الاغلب انت
ستقارن نفسك بدائرتك المحيطه بك فقط
وبالتالي قد تشعر بعدم الرضا اذا وجدت انك
لا تجني مثل المقربين هو نقاش دائر بين
الاكاديمين وباحثي علم السلوك كاجرى عليها
الباحثون اكثر من دراسه والنتيجه واحده
معظمنا غير راض عن راتبه حتى اصحاب الاجور
الكبيره
سعيا وراء معيشه اكثر رفاهيه على كل حال
حديثنا اليوم ليس عن زياده الرواتب ولكن
حولها طريقه تقسيم هذا الراتب واداره
الراتب الشهري بالشكل الامثل ليكون كافي
على الاقل
كيف نقسم هذا الراتب حتى لو كان مبلغا
كبيرا هو الحقيقه زي ما قلنا الفتره اللي
فاتت دي خصوصا مع التضخم وزياده الاسعار
اللي كلنا شايفينها كل حد بيحس ان في خلال
شهر او اقل من شهر الراتب بتاعه بينخفض
فلو فضلنا بالشكل ده تقريبا الراتب بتاعه
هينعدم بعد فتره وخصوصا في دول عربيه او
في حتى في امريكا او في اوروبا فالحل
بدايه ان احنا نعكس العمليه ان احنا عاده
بنعيش ان احنا بنصرف الفلوس وما يتبقى
منها ممكن نخليه او ان احنا نحوشه لو
عكسنا المفهوم بتاعنا ان احنا اول ما يبقى
الراتب يدخل لنا ان احنا نحدد بالظبط ايه
المبلغ اللي احنا هنستقطعه شهريا قبل ما
نشوف اي مصروفات ان هو ده الحد الادنى
اللي احنا هنحطه على جنب مبلغ كل شهر
نستقطعه من الراتب بتاعنا ونحطه على جنب
راتبنا 10,000 دولار نستقطع
بتختلف على حسب كل فئه على حسب كل دخل
شهري وعلى حسب اللي انت تقدر تستقطعه
ولنفترض ان انت تستقطع 10% من دخلك الشهري
دلوقتي وتحطه على جنب وتبدا بعدها تحسب
مصروفاتك هتلاقي اكيد خصوصا الناس اللي
كانت بتستخدم مرتبها ان في حاجات مضطر ان
هو يستغنى عنها وفي الغالب الحاجات دي
ممكن ما تكونش اساسيه يعني انت مثلا من
المدخنين ممكن يقدر يقلل من استهلاكه
للتدخين مع ان اسعارها بتزيد دلوقتي
وبتاكل اكتر من اللازم من راتب الشهري
ممكن يلاقي بعض المصروفات اللي كان
بيعملها ما كانتش اساسيه او ضروريه هتيجي
على حساب العشره في الميه دي فمجرد ان انت
شهر في التالي بدات تجمع العشر في الميه
هتعمل بعدها حاجه اسمها امرجنسي فاند كلنا
شفنا بعد الكورونا في ناس فجاه اتفاجات
بالظبط كده حساب للطوارئ ان لا قدر الله
حد تعب محتاج علاج حد فقد وظيفته فجاه
بقرار من الشركه يعمله تسريح للعماله يبقى
معاه مبلغ يكفي ان هو يقدر يعيش لمده ست
شهور على الاقل فبعد ما عمل او حساب
الطوارئ الست شهور ده يعني اللي هو حط 10%
يبتدي يحسب بيصرف كم في الشهر هيقعد كم
شهر يعمل يحطوا معاه يبقى هو ده مبلغ
بتاعه بعد ما اكتمل المبلغ ده يبدا يفكر
في مفهوم الاستثمار لان مفهوم الاستثمار
دلوقتي بدا يزداد شعبيه وبدات الناس تفكر
فيه اكتر بس في بعض الاحيان الناس بتعمله
بشكل غير محسوب ممكن يدخل بكل الفلوس اللي
معاه بدون علم بدون خبره بدون اي حاجه
ويخسر كل المبلغ اللي هو دخله فبدايه عملت
او الحساب اللي انت بتحطه الطوارئ بعدها
هنفكر في الاستثمار